A pesar de ser un pequeño país de apenas
20 millones de habitantes, durante al menos
las últimas 7 décadas Taiwan ha sido uno
de esos puntos calientes de la política internacional.
Su nombre oficial no es Taiwan sino “República
de China”. Y es que su origen se encuentra
en el país que surgió en China tras la revolución
de Xinhai de 1912. Una revolución que supuso
la caída de la Dinastía Qing.
Sin embargo la historia no termina ahí. Pocos
años después China iba a vivir una nueva
catarsis con la invasión del Imperio de Japón,
que logró controlar la parte más rica y
poderosa del país, y cuya capitulación en
1945 sirvió como caldo de cultivo para que
estallara una nueva guerra por el poder: la de
los comunistas de Mao contra los republicanos
nacionalistas del Kuomintang.
Y ya os podéis imaginar quién ganó, ¿verdad?
Mao logró establecer su república popular
en la China continental, mientras que los
líderes contrarrevolucionarios y lo que quedaba
de su ejército se establecieron en la isla
de Formosa.
Allí formaron un estado considerado durante
décadas como el legítimo sucesor del modelo
de gobierno que existía antes de la invasión
de japón y la posterior revolución comunista.
Es decir, para que nos entendamos el legítimo
gobierno de la República de China.
(Y así, durante más de 30 años el gobierno
nacionalista de Taiwan fue para muchos países
el interlocutor válido, el gobierno auténtico
de China. El heredero de la revolución de
Xinhai. El gobierno cuya legitimidad abarcaba
todo el país.
Bajo esa persecpetiva el régimen de Mao no
era más que un gobierno que ocupaba ilegitimamente
buena parte del país.
De hecho, esa ha sido tradicionalmente la
reinvindación de las autoridades taiwanesas.
Y ojo porque no hablamos precisamente de una
democracia sino también de una ferrea dictadura
bajo el control de Chiang Kai Sek. Para que
os hagais una idea hasta 1996 no se celebraron
elecciones libres.
A pesar de ello, gracias a su alianza con
Estados Unidos, hasta el año 1971, la República
de China, es decir Taiwán, ocupó el asiento
que le corresponde a China en la ONU en detrimento
de la República Popular fundada y pilotada
por Mao Zedong.)
Sin embargo, en 1971 todo empezó a cambiar.
Ese año Taiwan perdió su asiento en la ONU
a favor de la República Popular China.
[Claro, a ver, un país sólo puede tener
un representación en la ONU. Y si hay dos
gobiernos que se consideran legítimos pues…
hay que optar por uno u otro.
Porque amigos, esta es la clave, Taiwan nunca
se ha considera como un país independiente,
sino como la legimia China. ¡Qué follón!]
El caso es que a partir de ahí, a partir
de ese momento el reconocimiento internacional
y la influencia de Taiwán no han hecho más
que caer en picado.
Ahora bien, ¿qué sucedió con aquel Taiwán
que un día fue reconocido plenamente por
todas las grandes potencias occidentales?
¿Qué ocurre ahora que la China continental
se ha convertido en toda una superopotencia?
¿Qué ha ocurrido con la reivindicación
de Taiwan?
Y lo que es todavía más importante, ¿qué
podemos esperar tras las enormes protestas
que se han producido en Hong Kong, y las recientes
elecciones presidenciales de enero de 2020
en Taiwan?
¡Atentos!
(DE HEREDERO LEGÍTIMO A INCORDIO POLÍTICO)
Tal y cómo os hemos dicho, durante muchos
años el gobierno de Taiwán fue para la mayoría
de los países el representante soberano de
la nación china.
Pero, claro, la cada vez mayor influencia
de la República Popular China en la región
junto al despertar económico del gigante
asiático, le dieron la vuelta a la tortilla.
Taiwán perdió el reconocimiento de todos
los países salvo unas pocas excepciones,
que cada vez son menos y cada vez de países
más pequeños.
Estados Unidos, su mayor aliado, cambió el
reconocimiento hacia la República Popular
China en detrimento de la República de China
bajo la Administración Carter en 1979,.
Actualmente solo 14 países además del Vaticano
reconocen a la República de China como el
Estado válido para China.
(Esta situación y el hecho de que incluso
los más férreos aliados de Taiwán dejasen
de reconocerlos de iure, hizo que el gobierno
isleño abandonase su aspiración de reconocimiento
como gobierno legítimo de China a principios
de la década de 1990.
Desde entonces, Taiwán ha relajado sus esfuerzos
de reconocimiento y ha optado por una una
estrategia que cada vez es más clara y cada
vez tiene más apoyo: no ser reconocido como
la República de China, sino únicamente como
Taiwán.)
[Lo que tiene todo el sentido del mundo]
Amigos, los taiwaneses han comprendido de
una vez por todas que la construcción política,
social, económica y democrática que han
forjado con el paso de los años en la isla
les ha distanciado por completo de la China
continental.
Política y socialmente Taiwan es completamente diferente a lo
que se vive en la República Popular China
bajo la dictadura del Partido Comunista.
Son diferencias que cada vez más la sociedad
taiwanesa y también el gobierno de la isla
entienden ya como insalvables, y contra las
que no merece la pena luchar.
Simple y llanamente Taiwan es otro país.
(“La supresión de Taiwán por parte de
China de la arena internacional no puede cambiar
el indisputable hecho de la existencia de
Taiwán, ni puede obligar al pueblo taiwanés
a abandonar su modo de vida democrático y
libre.” - Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores
de Taiwán)
Podemos decir que aquellos que hace solo un
par de generaciones fundaron un país de exiliados
a una isla han conseguido constituir una nación
independiente con rasgos propios.
Y esa es la idea que defiende precisamente
la actual Presidente y Premio VisualPolitik
2018, Tsai Ing Wen, del Partido Democrático
Progresista [De la que por cierto hablaremos
más tarde.]
Aunque eso sí, ojo. Esta no es una visión
única.
El Kuomitang, el otro gran partido
de Taiwan defiende una postura muy distinta:
buscar un mayor acercamiento y entendimiento
con el régimen chino.
Pero [ un momento, ¿hemos dicho Kuomintang?
¿Acaso no os suena ese nombre?]
Exacto, seguro que muchos os habéis dado
cuenta.
El Kuomintang es el partido fundado por los
líderes republicanos nacionalistas que lucharon
contra la revolución comunista China y fundaron
el Taiwán actual.
Sí sí, lo habéis entendido bien. Os estamos
diciendo, por increíble que parezca, que
el partido que antaño se enfrentó al régimen
chino es ahora el que aboga por hacerse amigo
suyo.
[Para que luego digan que en la política
no hay cambios. Ja. Esto se mueve más que
una batidora de 4 palos]
Ahora bien, la pregunta que nos podemos hacer
es… ¿Qué demonios ha propiciado semejante
cambio?
Pues amigos, en todo esto la pasta juega un
papel primordial. Sí, sí, la pasta. Y no
refiero a las coimas, sobornos o arreglos
de todo tipo, sino a la posibilidad de sacar
provecho de la enorme economía que se ha
desarrollado en la China continental.
Y es precisamente aquí dónde nos surge una
gran pregunta: ¿Tu que escogerías?
¿Luchar por la plena independencia de tu
país aunque supusiera poder perder relaciones
económicas con el gigante asiáticos o buscar
un entendimiento con Pekín?
Pues, amigos, no penseis que es una pregunta
menor. Esa es la gran pregunta que se hacen
los taiwaneses y cuya respuesta determina
el resultado electoral.
(Ahora bien, hay una cuestión pendiente de
responder. ¿Qué ha ocurrido exactamente
con Taiwan a medida que ha ido perdiendo el
reconocimiento internacional? ¿Acaso se ha
quedado aislado?
Pues… No. Taiwán, es toda una excepción,
no tiene la consideración propia de país
pero si tiene un reconocimiento internacional
de facto sobre su soberanía y autogobierno.
Sus antiguas embajadas se han convertido en
“oficinas económicas y culturales”, que
actúan como embajadas, también de facto.
Los taiwaneses tienen documentos de identidad
y pasaportes propios expedidos por su gobierno
que son reconocidos internacionalmente.)
Y eso, esto es algo que saca de quicio a Pekín.
Pocas cosas molestan tanto en el gobierno
de la República Popular China que ver como
Taiwan es a todas luces un país independiente.
(Taiwán debe reunirse y se reunirá con China.
La independencia solo traerá dificultades
y la unificación con el continente es un
requisito inevitable para el gran rejuvenecimiento
del pueblo chino". Xi Jinping)
Pero no penseis que se quedan de brazos cruzados.
Para nada. El gobierno chino, el gobierno
de Xi Jinping lleva años acosando a la isla
con estrategias de desgaste continuo.
¿Cómo? Seguro que muchos os lo imaginais.
Amigos, la billetera china da mucho, pero
que mucho de sí; y no penseis que son pocos
los países que están dispuestos a pasar
de Taiwan a cambio de algún puñado que otro
de inversiones.
¿Habeís escuchado eso de que el dinero obra
milagros? Pues… exactamente eso.
Ahora bien, un momento, todo esto no significa,
ni mucho menos, que Taiwán esté solo en
el mundo. Eso China no lo ha conseguido [Lo
que también les saca de quicio.]
Aunque solo sea reconocido diplomáticamente
por un puñado de gobiernos, los taiwaneses
conservan muchos aliados e intereses comunes
con muchos países. Especialmente un acuerdo
vigente desde finales de los años 70 con
Estados Unidos por el que la gran potencia
norteamerica asegura que la isla estará surtida
de material militar.
(“Los cambios en el terreno diplomático
son sin duda un reto. Pero Taiwán tiene todavía
muchos amigos alrededor del mundo dispuestos
a estar de nuestro lado, y no estamos solos.”
- Tsai Ing Wen, presidenta de Taiwán.)
Así que tal y como ya os comentamos en un
pasado vídeo que os dejo en la descripción
el gobierno de Taiwán ha optado por la estrategia
de la diferenciación:
nosotros no tenemos nada que ver con China,
somos Taiwán y no pretendemos mandar sobre
nadie más que sobre nosotros mismos, ni que
nadie mande sobre nosotros.
Ese es el mensaje de la presidenta Tsai que
ha calado ondo entre los votantes taiwaneses.
En las recientes elecciones presidenciales,
la victoria de Tsai ha sido arrolladora: se
ha hecho con el 58% de los votos. Le ha sacado
casi 20 puntos al Kuomitang de Han Kuo Yu.
Vamos, que más que una victoria lo que ha
hecho Tsai electoralmente es coger una apisonadora,
tumbar a los candidatos en el asfalto y pasarles
por encima.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué los taiwaneses han
votado de esta forma a pesar de las constantes
advertencias de Pekín respecto a un nuego
gobierno de Tsai Weng?
Atentos.
(TAIWÁN, TERMÓMETRO DEL EXPANSIONISMO CHINO)
Amigos, las recientes elecciones de enero
de 2020 en Taiwán han sido una tremenda bofetada
democrática al régimen de Pekín.
Con la lección aprendida ante los sucesos
de los últimos meses en Hong Kong, los taiwaneses
le han visto más que nunca las orejas al
lobo.
(Las constantes intromisiones de Pekín en
los asuntos hongkongeses violando el estatus
especial de la ciudad y las enormes protestas
reclamando libertad han servido a los taiwaneses
para perder la poquísima confianza que les
quedaba en China.
Por eso han votado en contra de la confianza
que el Kuomintang tiene en Pekín.
Una confianza que, ellos dicen, se traduciría
en estabilidad económica [vamos, dinerito
chino] y paz en la región [es decir, reducir
la influencia de Estados Unidos].
Sin embargo, la opinión del pueblo taiwanes
ha sido muy diferente. Los casi 20 puntos
de diferencia cocsechados por Tsai Ing Wen
suponen la mayor victoría electoral desde
que hay elecciones libres en el país.)
(Los resultados de estas elecciones tienen
un significado adicional. Han demostrado que
cuando nuestra soberanía se ve amenazada,
el pueblo taiwanés mostrará aún más nuestra
determinación. Tsai Ing Wen)
Tsai ha sabido canalizar perfectamente el
miedo de los taiwaneses a perder sus libertades
por la influencia de China, y ha llegado a
ser especialmente contundente en su discurso
de cierre de campaña. Fijaos:
(“La gente joven de Hong Kong ha utilizado
sus vidas, así como su sangre y lágrimas,
para demostrarnos a nosotros que “un país,
dos sistemas” no puede funcionar. Mañana,
dejemos a los jóvenes de Taiwán demostrarles
a ellos que los valores de la democracia,
y la libertad superarán todas las dificultades.”
- Tsai Ing Wen, presidenta de Taiwán.)
Estas dificultades a las que se refiere Tsai
son, ni más ni menos, que el aislamiento
político internacional y la pérdida de inversiones.
El gigante chino está empecinado en aislar
a Taipei para ahogar su economía y obligarles
a rendirse a a sus exigencias si quieren mantener
a flote su nivel de vida.
Objetivo para el que no están dudando en
usar su enorme billetera.
Lo hemos visto en última instancia con dos
de los pocos países que todavía reconocían
a Taiwán como gobierno legítimo de China:
las Islas Salomón y Kiribati.
(China extiende su influencia en el Pacífico
al romper las Islas Salomón con Taiwán - The
Guardian)
(Taiwán pierde otro aliado al cortar lazos
Kiribati - BBC)
Dos pequeños territorios en el Pacífico
pero que podrían ser clave para Estados Unidos
en la contención de las aspiraciones expansionistas
chinas.
Aunque ahora la balanza parece inclinada más
que nunca hacia Pekín.
De los 14 países que todavía reconocen a
Taiwán, solo quedan cuatro en el área del
Pacífico sur.
Y el reconocimiento o no de Taiwán por estos
países representa implícitamente el nivel
de adhesión a Estados Unidos frente a China.
(La dejadez de los Estados Unidos en esta
parte del mundo y el gigantesco poder de disuasión
del dinero chino ha hecho que no hagan falta
guerras ni barcos militares amenazantes para
asegurarse el control de unos mares clave
para el comercio mundial.)
Pero… NO, nos desviemos.
El caso es que ahora con otros cuatro años
de la independentista Tsai al frente de Taiwán,
se espera que las relaciones con Pekín lleguen
a ser más frías que tomarse un helado en
pleno Artico. Y cuando hablamos de relaciones
diplomáricas y China… hablamos habitualmente
de bloqueo económico.
Ese es el reto al que se enfrenta la Presidente
Tsai… Porque amigos, si una cosa han defendido
en Pekín por activa y por pasiva es que nunca
toleraran la plena independencia de Taiwan.
(Rechazamos el modelo de un país, dos sistemas.
Valoramos el estilo de vida de la democracia
y defenderemos nuestra soberanía ”. Tsai
Weng)
Pero llegados a este punto turno para tí,
¿Si fueras taiwanes que escogerías China
o negocios? ¿Crees que Taiwan podrá prosperar
al margen del gigante asiático? Dejanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también en
esta encuesta.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.